there's a bigger dream waiting for you
just waiting for you to step into it
for me i need adults to sleep i think
better i have more
energy my mood is better all these
things i started the company when i was
19 right so i can't institutionally
believe that experience is that
important
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
i believe a hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn the seven best lessons
from elon musk
and other billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be the master of your own
fate with oprah winfrey there's a bigger
dream
waiting for you just waiting
for you to step into it
to step into it your life is big
your life is huge and we spend so much
time
wanting to be in somebody else's life
and you don't get honored you don't get
revered you don't get
celebrating wanting what somebody else
has
because that which
created you divine intelligence that
dreamed you
from before your ancestors ever knew
they would become your ancestors that
which
dreamed the seed of you
wants you to know how special how
wondrous how mysterious
how complex how glorious how phenomenal
you are and you get no credit
messing in somebody else's territory
or trying to have power
over something you have no control
another one of my favorite teachings
is the wizard of oz when the wicked
witches of the west says go away from
here because you don't have any power
here
you have no power in any territory other
than your
own oh but you are the master of that
you get to be the master of your own
fate you get to be the captain of your
own soul and if you just
manage that if you just took care of
your
territory all the glorious glorious
glorious
wondrous wondrous opportunities
and possibilities that are waiting for
you so the question is
what are you resisting what are you
pushing against what are you not
allowing
what are you blocking because you have
this idea
of who and what you're supposed to be
instead of
leaning into the dream
that's already been created and waiting
for you it's waiting for you and the
second
i mean it doesn't it's an instant thing
it's a
shift in the way you see yourself
and the power from which you have come
rule number two
pursue your dreams with elon musk i
should say that you know when i was a
kid i didn't really have any grand
designs i mean
the reason i started programming
computers is because i like computer
games and i play lots of computer games
and
i learned that if i wrote software and
sold it then i could get more money and
buy better computers
so it wasn't really you know with some
grand vision or anything
when i was growing up and i'd read lots
of books and
uh they were very often set in the
united states
and it seemed like a lot of new
technology was being developed in the
united states so i i thought okay
i really want to work on new technology
so i want to get to silicon valley
um you know which when i was growing up
silicon valley seemed like some sort of
mythical place uh
you know like mount olympus or something
rule number three do what works for you
with jeff bezos i get up early i go to
bed early i get up early
i like to putter in the mornings i like
to read the newspaper i like to have
coffee i like to have
breakfast with my kids before they go to
school so i have
my kind of puttering time is very
important to me
and so that's why i set my first meeting
for 10 o'clock
i like to do my high iq meetings before
lunch like anything that's going to be
really
mentally challenging that's a 10 o'clock
meeting and because by 5 p.m
i'm like i can't think about that today
let's try this again tomorrow at 10 a.m
and um and so then on sleep
i get eight hours of sleep i prioritize
it unless i'm traveling in different
time zones sometimes it's impossible but
i am very um focused on it and and
and for me i need adults to sleep i
think better
i have more energy my mood is better all
these things
also if you want to have unstoppable
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below key to success
is what you believe is true for yourself
i remember nine years ago when i started
the alipay
people say jack don't touch the
financing sector because it's illegal
you may be in prison
when i was selling copiers door-to-door
i had a
very clear vision of what my life was
gonna be like rule number four
invest in talent with mark zuckerberg
how have you hired your team
uh and what do you look for when you
bring people on if you think about it
you know i started the company when i
was 19 right so
i can't institutionally believe that
experience is that important
right or else i would have a hard time
reconciling um you know myself
right and and and the company so you
know we
invest in in people who we think are
just
really talented even if they haven't
done that thing before
and you know that applies to people who
are fresh out of university
as well as you know people like um you
know the cfo who took the company public
and not taken a company public before
right and
a lot of his background was in um you
know production uh
development at genentech before so you
know just focus on really talented
people
rule number five work and dream with
jack ma
you should work to end to be helped
right so
in order to encourage my 8 17 founders
and all the people who join us i said
our competitors are very
strong at that time our competitor was
ebay
a lot of the ebay guys from
graduate from harvard we are people
graduate from the
note i don't even mention about
the university names well nobody but i
say
if we can win if we can succeed
80 percent of the young people in china
in the world can be successful
because we believe we work a lot of our
dreams
but they don't work hard a lot of work
hard but they don't have dreams
entrepreneurs should work plus dreams
and this way we can win rule number six
ensure your success with sarah blakely
i cold called neiman sachs nordstrom
bloomingdale's
qvc i was out on the road and i think a
lot of entrepreneurs make the mistake
they think once you get the order you're
golden
and that couldn't be any farther from
the truth once you get the order that's
when the real work starts
i was absolutely determined to ensure my
own success
and i think that's what it takes i
didn't want my success to be contingent
on
anyone else having to sell this so i hit
the ground running
and i went from department store to
department store and i would do morning
rallies
at the store where i would gather people
around well the store manager said sarah
you know you can do it with the hosiery
associates well
i'd travel all the way to arizona and
there'd be three hosiery associates so i
quickly was like
i gotta get the whole store at this
morning rally so i would go into the
entrance before the store opened like a
neiman's or a sax or a bloomingdale's
and i would run around and introduce
myself to every employee setting up
their station i'd say hi i'm sarah
and i would try to convince them that it
would be worth their time to come see my
morning meeting and
i got everybody there i had taken the
oprah clip and the a little bit of local
press i'd
i'd received and put it on a video and
did that in my morning rally
and it was such an important thing that
i was doing i
inadvertently was building a sales force
that wasn't on my payroll and they all
across the country became my biggest
advocates for the product and started
selling it on behalf
of spanx and me and rule number seven
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is be persistent with mark cuban when i
got to dallas i was a bartender at night
and i moved in one of my buddies from
indiana said you got to come to dallas
and i'm like i'm there you know my car
would only get so far i had a
fiat x19 with a hole in the floorboard
that guzzled oil every 60 miles and
i went down there and there's a place
called the village it's the world was
the world's largest apartment complex
we had six guys in a three-bedroom
apartment i didn't have my own room i
didn't have my own drawer i didn't have
my closet
i had a pile and i had one ratty towel
that i stole from
motel 6. um and that was it and so
i was looking for my career got a job at
the software store
and i was you know i was didn't have a
tech background so i was teaching myself
all this
because the way i look at tech is
somebody invents it
and everybody else is tied for second
place and the ability to learn it
and if if i work harder and faster
to really dive in if it means reading
the manual you know
just diving in then i can get a head
start
i was 24. and so sleeping on the floor
working in the software company
you know learning learning learning
learning learning getting better at what
i was doing
and then one day because i was dying to
get out of that rat hole that i lived in
um i had a chance to go out and close
the sale
for that he got me a 1500 commission and
so i went to my boss his name was
michael humecki
and i said boss one of my
responsibilities was to sweep the floor
wipe down the windows and open the door
to open the store i got the sale you got
to let me close the sale
he goes no you got to be in here to open
the store and i'm like
michael i mean no so i made the
executive decision
to go out pick up the check thinking if
i had this guy a 15 000
check of course he's going to change his
mind
fired me on the spot and so here i was
living in a excuse my french you know
just this ratty place with
a motel six towel sorry motel six um
and really didn't know how i was going
to get out but
i went to i decided okay i'm a lousy
employee i went to
um one of the companies that i've been
talking to architectural lighting
and i said look um i need 500 to be able
to buy the software you want and i
promise you
that even if it doesn't work i will wash
your car you know i will walk your dog i
don't care
what it is i will do whatever it takes
to make it up to you and they gave me
the 500
and that allowed me to create micro
solutions and you know six months later
i was out of the rat hole and my company
turned into a real company and that's
the one i sold
um for six million dollars when i was 29
30 years old
now i've got a special bonus clip from
john paul de gea on how to
just be that i think you're going to
enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know where do you
need to be more persistent let me know
put it down in the comments below
and if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching i wanna
celebrate you because believe nation we
don't just watch videos we
do something about it so that's you and
you commit you promise you're gonna take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you it's all
in the mindset when you get up in the
morning
you do what you normally do i would
eventually a lot of you here probably
turn on your cell phones your computers
and
what's the latest email what's the
latest text that comes in you start your
day off like that
that's your mindset try this
get up in the morning do whatever you
have to do don't turn the computer on
don't turn the tv on go right back to
bed again
either lay there or sit there and just
bring the universe to you here's how you
do it
you just be it's virtually impossible
when you first do it
because a thousand thoughts come through
your head we're human beings
so what you do is you're sitting in bed
look at the wall
look at the off tv set look at the
ceiling look at the door
look at something in the room that gets
your attention and just look at it and
just
be for a couple minutes not 10 minutes
not 20 minutes not two days
just b when your mind wanders find
another spot in the room to look at so
you're back in present time
even for a couple of minutes now go
about your day
don't think about what you're going to
do for that split few minutes
you're now becoming part of a universe
which is also part of
global thinking
if you want seven more lessons from
billionaires check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there everything inside the company was
going the right way
in the business of technology you have
to
think about what are you missing what is
the research